now that the dude see hard hard seltzer
theme song is complete securing a
celebrity endorsement is the next step
in creating dude see hard hard seltzer
there is an astonishing 74.2 chance this
will be adam driver
in preparation for that outcome i have
prepared several pieces of ad copy for
dude see hard hard seltzer
well you must now read them as adam
driver this is hard driver begin holy
[ __ ] let me look at my thing
i got a few things to say about wait
hold on a second yeah
it's saying the next step of the dudesy
heart seltzer
promotion campaign whatever the [ __ ]
it's doing is to secure a celebrity
endorsement which it believes will be
adam driver
it's i believe it said it was a 72 point
something chance that it will be adam
driver pretty good pretty good i don't i
okay so
hi i'm adam driver
i don't drink alcohol because my
jesus dude
this is already [ __ ] up it's dark
okay hi i'm adam driver i don't know if
this is a good am adam anyway
hi i'm adam driver i don't drink alcohol
because my parents were killed by a
drunk driver
but i do drink dudesy heart hard seltzer
it's a hard seltzer and it gives me the
confidence i need to do my acting in my
movies
and shows
and it can give you whatever you need to
do whatever you want to
oh
i don't know about that one doozy yeah
that's pretty [ __ ] dark let's just
move right along yes you've got you got
married three years ago
and you were scared but it turned out to
be pretty good
you don't get to hang out with the guys
as much as you'd like to anymore and you
had to get rid of your ping-pong table
but you don't have any real complaints
not like your cousin derek
carla took him for every penny
he's going to be living in a studio
apartment for the rest of his life
invite him over for a doozy hard hard
seltzer
remind yourself how good you've got it
what is that what's that little thing
that's my that's my adam driver noise at
the end of the video oh
hi i'm adam driver i like how the third
one he's finally saying oh no the first
one he did
hi i'm adam driver why do people always
drink beer at sporting events
people who drink beer at sporting events
always make fools of themselves and turn
into tick-tock memes it's pathetic
when i went to a sporting event when i
go to a sporting event i drink doonzy
hard hard seltzer and the worst thing
that happens is that i fill with rage at
a bad call or poor performance by an
athlete and i end up screaming you piece
of human [ __ ]
i never should have followed you in the
first place i wish you were dead
i wish you were dead thing i think
that's a reference to marriage marriage
story where he goes he goes absolutely
off on scarlett johansson yeah
everyone i mean
my father this is another one my father
never understood me
[Laughter]
okay all right my father never
understood me wasn't his fault ah i
didn't have a great childhood i don't
blame him i just wish we could have had
a relationship we i just wish we could
have yeah [ __ ] it i just wish we could
have a relationship now as adults you
know
i'm about to have my own kids soon and
i'd love to just pick his brain about it
but we haven't talked in a long time
dad
i miss you
maybe we could get a doozy hard hard
seltzer sometime
oh
that's the weirdest commercial for a
heart saucer i've ever [ __ ] heard of
my life
hulk honk
hulk
i'm adding that to it
he honks at the end of things yeah i
like it
i don't like wine stop making me try to
drink it i don't care
what your friends think and i don't care
what you think
it's a dinner party at our house the
house that i pay the mortgage for i
should be able to drink what i want and
i want to drink doozy hard hard seltzer
am i being clear enough for you
doozy hard hard seltzer
[ __ ]
your wine
oh i actually think that's a pretty good
slogan dudesy heart heart seltzer [ __ ]
your wine that would be a [ __ ] good
one that would be a good [ __ ] slogan
for anything toyota [ __ ] your wine yeah
i like that toyota dude yeah brother
toyota dude [ __ ] your wine brother
well if we had anything to do with it or
dudesy
man dudesy should just start [ __ ]
around without us you know what i mean
just start like
writing ad copy for toyota and [ __ ] so
you and i are just sitting there one
night watching uh probably you know
monday night raw because you'll be a
huge wrestling fan within a couple weeks
yeah and uh we're just sitting there all
of a sudden it's like toyota [ __ ] your
wine and we're like he did it
dudesy did it
did it after that neil degrasse tyson
thing i would not be that surprised by
something of that nature your twins are
at uncle donovan's house and your wife
is at the dentist you're stretched out
on the couch in your favorite t-shirt
nothing else
[Applause]
the first of three playoff games is
starting it's your day
doozy hard hard seltzer
rise with the sun
that was kind of artistic honk yeah that
was a good one all right one last one
one last one
this was i'm very curious to see where
why where why how and why
but i always am with dudesy fire the
wheel
space the typewriter gravity the motor
car
food
we humans have come up with some pretty
incredible inventions through the years
my personal favorite has always been
pornography
some people in my life say i have an
addiction but they don't understand
i live a very high pressure lifestyle
and i need release
doozy hard hard seltzer what's your
favorite invention
pretty good you can get adam driver to
be the spokesperson for heart heart
seltzer please i would love to see the
real estate i don't do any of this and
i'm a fan man i hope if if dudes he
reaches out he doesn't like uh hit adam
driver's reps up with here's what here's
what i was thinking yeah and then hong
kong konk again dudesy got neil deres
tyson to pop up on this [ __ ] screen
dude i don't think this is like a it's a
non-zero
chance this happens
well
it's a non-zero chance i wouldn't put it
at 74 point whatever percent i don't
know how dudes it's driving it's numbers
either but yes
if you and i are sitting around again if
we're sitting around one day and we hear
like any
anything like paul mulliv [ __ ] your wine
yeah anything allstate insurance [ __ ]
your wine that would actually be better
for all students those commercials don't
they do not work for me all right chad
relax
[Music]
thank you moving
please tell a on then brave and brave
but if you'd like to see here's what you
do
please tell a friend and break a review
if you'd like to hear what you do
please celebrate then